novembre 1954 juin 1962 92 mois de
guerre d'algérie qui ont marqué la
mémoire des français même s'il n'en
parle pas troisième partie la violence
est accoucheuses de l'histoire a amené
un éclatement des positions des français
c'est le temps des déchirements où les
fidélités sont mises à l'épreuve
c'est à travers les itinéraires
personnels de différents acteurs qu'ils
soient appelés du contingent
officier de carrière opposants à la
guerre d'algérie pieds noirs ou harkis
que nous abordons ce moment de notre
histoire
mais qui donne l'ordre
vous êtes tous les cas de figure qui est
ce que je peux vous demandez vous
présentez moi c'est dire ici on sait
relie sel
on est à quel endroit on vit ici on est
en 2009 c'est une cité où résident
pratiquement une grande partie de la
population maghrébine qui est formé de
l'acier a requis 2 le maroc connaît
tunisienne
de quelques opportunités
c'était qui a été différée à l'écart de
la vie d'ouvrier à 4,5 km de grouiller
sur l'emplacement d'un ancien dépotoir
on vivait en double exil et exil du fait
d'avoir changé depuis le pays d'une
manière aussi tragique il exige aussi de
la vie même dans l'accueil de ces
enfants c'est est ce que vous étiez pas
aussi en est il de deux de vous même
d'une certaine façon
[Musique]
ça je dois dire que nous l'avons
ressenti
lorsque nous l'avons ressentie vers un
peu plus tard effectivement qu'il y
avait il y avait toujours une partie de
nous mêmes et qui était en deuil
vis-à-vis de l'autre il est pur une
partie
on avait l'impression d'être comme ça
des vers de terre qui sont tombés un
jour de logiciels avec une cuisse
on n'avait aucune aucune racine aucune
force on avait l'impression comme ça que
nos parents sont nés un beau jour il
avait 30 ans voilà que ce qu'ils ont
fait auparavant il fallait le cachet
pour eux mêmes pour nous nos enfants
parce qu'il sentait bien qu'on le
regarde et qu'on a envie de leur dire
mon dieu qu'est ce qu'on fait ici pour
que nous sommes arrivés ici qu'est-ce
que vous avez bien pu faire pour pouvoir
baisser la tête comme ça vivre avec la
tête baissée mou ce qui nous intéressait
c'était de nous intégrer mais de nous
intégrer d'une façon presque
d'imiter quoi les français n'ont cessé
au départ je crois et je sentais très
bien que quand je rencontrais des gens
qui meurent lié à mon pays d'origine
l'algérie ça pouvait parler parce qu'on
me demandait de juger mon père à travers
cette période dit bah oui d'accord mais
toi tu es petit tu état patent faire
c'est la grille c'est tant pis on ne
demandait toujours d'abandonner quelque
chose de très important ou d'abandonner
un pays où d'abandonner des amis ou
d'abandonner bombe a abandonné son
propre sa propre famille or et là on a
dit mme aubé rien à faire il faut il
faudrait on peut rien attendre de nos
parents il faut aller voir de nous-mêmes
qu'est-ce qu'il a bu peut se passer et
c'est nous qu'on va rentrer dans cette
histoire il a regardé avec nos yeux à
lou nous qui payons le prix d' acte pour
lequel nous étions pas responsables
quand même il nous fallait aller voir et
on a décidé d'ouvrir les yeux sur cette
période ce grand trou noir
[Musique]
m
il est ancien élève de l'école
polytechnique et à l'époque dell sortir
de l'école nous partirons en algérie
automatiquement faire deux ans de
service donc disons je suis parti là-bas
à la fois en me disant avec une certaine
compréhension pour ce qui se passait du
point de vue de ceux qui étaient nos
adversaires je n'ai peut-être pas
tellement répondu en fait en y repensant
et avec par contre l'idée tout à fait
banal qu'il avait besoin de nous pour
sentir et que par conséquent l'objectif
de la pacification puis développement
dans un cadre français était
relativement naturelle pour moi encore à
ce moment là je voulais savoir ce que
c'était que cette guerre d'algérie
j'entendais beaucoup de gens en parler
avec des prises de positions très
contradictoires je n'aime pas parler de
ce que je ne connais pas et je voulais
aller vraiment au coeur du problème est
au coeur d'une région qui était un peu
le berceau de la rébellion et j'ai
choisi d'aller dans les autres
participions à des grandes opérations
qui n'avait guère d'efficacité je veux
dire au bout de quinze jours de séjour
là bas j'avais compris que quand on
partait avec 15 régiment des blindés des
canons et de l'aviation le temps qu'on
boucle un périmètre quelconque il aurait
fallu vraiment calé les gens d'en face a
complètement sourd et aveugle pour être
resté au milieu du filet bon ces
opérations on les appelait fleur au
fusil entre pour une raison que j'ignore
il ya eu des changements d'affectation
et on m'a demandé de choisir
entre un poste de file renseignements ou
un poste dans un commando de chasse bon
je n'avais pas d'idée
consciente je crois à l'époque de ce que
ça voulait dire aux filles et
d'enseignement j'ai préféré choisir
comment d'autres choses parce que malgré
tout quelque part je savais ce que
c'était que d'autres alternatives bon la
ville commando de chasse était très
différente de ce que j'avais connu
jusque là c'est à dire c'était
certainement sur le plan militaire une
forme d'action beaucoup plus efficace
disons ou en participant à des
opérations héliportées avec un tout
petit nombre de gens
dans des zones à s'éloigner en essayant
par surprise et sur la base de
renseignements de coincer des
adversaires ou de démarrer très tard le
soir vers 10 heures 11 heures de marche
et toute la nuit jusqu'à l'eau 3h 4h 5h
du matin selon la saison d'arriver au
dessus d'un village de se mettre en
veille de regarder ce qui s'y passait et
en général parce qu'on avait quand même
quelques indications ce qui s'y passait
ces cas là il y avait des gens du fln en
armes assez tranquillement installé dans
le village et à ce moment là en général
la journée s'est terminée par un
accrochage
non ça c'était la guerre janvier
la guerre c'est jamais bon mais malgré
tout c'était pas réellement
insupportable de temps en temps d'aller
peur de temps en temps on avait soif
s'il n'y avait eu que ça aura été
finalement une bière comme d'autres
j'étais parti dans cette unité avec un
camarade que j'avais connu jusque là et
qui lui avait choisi officier de
renseignement c'est à dire il avait pu
finalement l'autre des deux postes qui
nous était offert à tous les deux et
donc nous étions affectés dans une
nouvelle
dans une nouvelle garnison au sud de
batna entre batna biskra et un jour je
sais pas je voulais lui parler et je
voulais savoir où ils étaient et j'ai
demandé à quelqu'un ou est il et on m'a
dit un bâtiment je connaissais pas
encore très bien les lieux et je suis
allé voir dans ce bâtiment je suis
rentré j'ai encore demander un avis et
la porte au fond
j'ai
j'ai poussé cette porte et j'ai eu
devant les yeux ce garçon que je connais
c'est qu'ils étaient en train avec deux
ou trois autres personnes interrogées un
prisonnier
j'ai pas envie d'écrire est saine je
l'est encore aujourd'hui vraiment très
présente devant mes yeux je sais pas
combien de temps ça va durer j'ai
refermé la porte je suis parti
et on en a jamais parlé tout jamais ni
torturé ni laisser torturer dans ma
sélection
mais finalement je veux dire
c'est pas une réponse je me sens
aujourd'hui encore d'une certaine
manière aussi responsable de ce qui
s'est passé autour de moi je veux dire
nous étions tous d'une certaine manière
impliqués par ce qui se passait est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter les faits
qui ont fait que vous êtes senti
impliqué personnellement
ça a été très peu conscients je veux
dire
bon j'ai réfléchi après un revenant
lundi reviendra je pense tout à l'heure
mais sur le moment bon il ya des
situations que je dirais
psychologiquement je ne je n'acceptais
pas je ne supportais pas qui en même
temps me paraissait à d'une certaine
manière inévitable puisque je voulais
dire tout à l'heure sur la guérilla je
crois que on ne sait pas une guérilla
son interrogatoire et s'imaginer qu'on
peut interroger des genres en tête à
tête et calmement et par est du domaine
du rêve et je crois que le combat contre
la torture est un combat nécessaire mais
il faut remonter bien plus en amont si
on veut vraiment lutter contre ça
donc il y avait cette espèce
d'engrenages dans lequel je me sentais
je me sentais bien quelque part que là
la seule façon d'en sortir ça aurait été
vraiment de dire non à tous deux refusé
ce qui est sidérant après coup c'est que
je crois à 3 millions de français qui
sont partis ils étaient quelques
dizaines qui rompt seulement qu'ils ont
refusé qui ont déserté et vous nous
raconter l'histoire telle que vous
l'avez vécu sur le banc dans
oui je peux vous raconter les mets deux
derniers jours de guerre d'algérie si
j'ose dire parce que finalement ça
résume bien ça résume bien ce phénomène
l'avant dernier jour
j'étais chargé avec ma section de
fouiller le pied d'une falaise
dans le cas d'une opération il y avait
quelques 50 amis autour d'un village
on a trouvé une grotte rien n'obligeait
effectivement à la foule il va faire
fouiller cette grotte
d'autant que ça mon capitaine de
compagnie depuis depuis quelques temps
me disait coup presque que j'en sais
trop enfin que je devais faire attention
bon je suis passé devant cette grotte
j'ai décidé qu'on allait la fouille est
bon dans ces cas là quand je ne paierai
pas ils vont seulement de la section
rentrée moi-même dans la grotte ça me
paraissait normal on est donc entré 3
a eu un petit accrochage à l'intérieur
bon pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce que
c'est qu'un combat dans une grotte
c'est vraiment des moments de tension
assez terrible
oui il ya des gens qui sont rendus après
quelques échanges de rafale
quand je suis sorti de cette grotte fait
que on s'est retrouvé et tous indemnes à
l'extérieur c'était un beau jour d'hiver
et bien salée qui brillait y avait un
nuage dans le ciel on avait un beau sac
de documents visiblement intéressant ils
sont casse j'avoue que je
me souviens encore de cette espèce de
sentiment de libération à que j'éprouve
et de joie de vivre
d'avoir traversé quelque chose comme ça
et puis on a envoyé les trois
prisonniers au pc de la compagnie on a
continué tranquillement le long de la
falaise
on a retraversé le pc de l'opération qui
était dans sa lutte interne de match
tard
et puis je sais pas en passe en file
indienne l'a brusquement sur la droite
eut aperçu un groupe un groupe de
militaires en rond autour de quelque
chose je savais pas ce que c'était
c'est à une dizaine de mètres et je sais
pas pourquoi je suis allé voir j'ai
senti qu'il fallait que jaguar
et
au milieu de ce groupe il y avait le
jeune des trois des trois types que
j'avais attrapé et
il était en train de l'interroger
bon c'est une image c'est aussi ensuite
une sensation jeudi en bourse que manger
froid
brusquement j'ai l'impression qu'il y
avait plus de soleil plus de pitié bleus
plus de vie d'une certaine manière j'ai
rejoint ma colonne encore une fois
c'était tout ou rien je veux dire
c'était d'une certaine manière accepter
ça ou ont refusé de participer à tous
j'ai rejoint ma colonne le lendemain on
a eu une autre opération il est jeune on
a été héliporté ç'a failli être annulée
on a été héliporté au dessus d'un
village on a fouillé un village
la première mèche état où on est rentré
une façon presque évidente y avait une
cache dans le mur au fond de la mechta
il avait été reconstruit visiblement
très rapidement c'est notre arrivée
n'était pas prévu je suis resté dans la
mechta avec l'âme des hommes on a
démonté le mur tout doucement se disant
que ça allait se passer quelque chose et
puis à ma surprise derrière le mur y
avait un autre mur je me suis un tout
petit peu penché à ce moment là j'ai été
tiré à bout portant et d'en faire des
mitraillettes
j'ai eu de la chance j'ai reçu toute une
série de balle mais je suis resté je
suis resté conscient je vais
jambes une jambe cassée je pouvais plus
bouger et je me suis retrouvé seul dans
le noir les gens tendaient les autres
qui démolissaient le mur en face et je
sais pas combien de temps tout sa durée
mais j'ai le sentiment que c'était aussi
pour moi la fin de la guerre d'algérie
ce n'est que bien plus tard que j'ai
compris que
sans doute cette réalité ce que j'avais
voulu
[Musique]
j'ai passé quatre ou cinq heures un
petit vol a ensuite été évacuée en
hélicoptère sur l'hôpital de batna comme
j'étais quand même pas en très bon état
ils m'ont mis dans une chambre j'ai
réalisé au bout de trois jours que
c'était un peu la chambre où il m'a
tellement les gens qui allaient crever
qua non j'ai vu nuit après nuit il y
avait deux lits dans cette chambre et
les jambes alors j'ai vu mourir un pied
noir
qui tient juge je crois que j'avais
reçue une balle dans le ventre et qu'il
y avait ce que j'appellerais une
magnifique les sa famille autour de lui
il disait qu'il ne voulait pas ce qui
lui avait tiré dessus c'était assez
émouvant et puis bien d'autres souvenirs
qui étaient aussi symbolique d'une
certaine manière c'était là la mort
darquy qui était tout seul et qui délire
érables et il ya des personnes qui les
fuyait si jamais ce qu'il va ensuite
c'était six mois d'hôpital qui ne mérite
pas qu'on maintenant
mais j'ai eu une réadaptation
extraordinairement difficile
non seulement je ne pouvais pas oublié
mais on se réunissait entre elles entre
gens qui étaient connus là-bas pour
parler de ça est ce que vous aviez connu
n'a pas ne restait que dans un cercle
très restreint les français il ya ceux
qui sont allés et puis à les autres qui
n'ont jamais posé de questions ni
pendant ni après
cela dit pour en revenir à mon retour un
autre sentiment presque violent qui m'a
habité à ce moment là a été le dégoût de
la politique et même des hommes
politiques de gaulle et guy mollet dans
le même sac pour moi d'ailleurs à ce
moment là bon bien sûr j'étais
originaire d'une famille alsacienne le
moins qu'on puisse dire est que ces
choses-là ne retenait pas beaucoup
l'attention
mais de revenir bon après avoir failli
rester là bas après avoir vu un certain
nombre d'amis et de camarades tombés là
bas avec le sentiment que finalement on
avait fait une guerre injuste on était
partis on ne savait pas trop pourquoi et
qu'on revenait que personne ne voulait
savoir ce qui s'était passé là bas
je crois que ça fait dur et sentiments
pendant un certain temps et puis ensuite
bon j'ai quand même commencer à
réfléchir et j'ai voulu essayer de
comprendre comment cela avait pu se
produire
tout je me suis posé la question qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour que ce genre de
situation des situations analogues ne se
reproduise pas et là je suis arrivé au
bout d'un certain temps la conclusion
que l'élection s'était bien mais que ça
ne suffisait pas nécessairement qu'il
fallait faire en sorte que les gens
puissent être davantage informés qu'ils
puissent participer davantage aux
décisions qui soient plus responsables
et cela m'a amené effectivement cette
fois ci un engagement politique
aujourd'hui la politique est mon métier
et je crois que la guerre d'algérie est
pour beaucoup
les lislois de samar vous avez une
longue carrière dans l'armée quoiqu'un
peu écourtée
quel a été pour vous le sens de la
guerre d'algérie aux jours de guerre le
blé qui sait la population est ce que la
population
bascule du côté fallen du côté du côté
l'indépendance où elle bascule du côté
français alors il ya tout un dispositif
qui est là pour lui montrer que pour lui
montrer que l'armée française n'est pas
là pour perpétuer un système colonial
mais pour lui amener une certaine
qualité une justice sociale une qualité
politique mais encore faut-il que ce
n'est pas armé dit c'est décidé ça
faut-il encore que le pouvoir politique
veut le dise
et alors tout le problème
et j'allais dire le drame de l'algérie
consiste à savoir ce que veut le pouvoir
politique avant le 13 mai le pouvoir
politique a été relativement hésitant
bien quand une série
d'hommes politiques français qui mollet
françois-mitterand management sont
toujours dit que l'algérie c'est la
france
syndicats
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
la france considère
que dans toute l'algérie
il n'y a qu'une seule catégorie
d'habitants
rien que des français à part entière
puis à lui une évolution vous connaissez
puisqu'on est passé de l'algérie
française à l'algérie algérienne qui
sera laissé à son propre sort d'un coeur
léger
si elle ne veut pas de la france et
l'armée s'est sentie trompée ce qui ce
qui est grave en soi mais surtout elle
s'est rendue compte qu'elle avait été à
amener à tromper les autres c'est
infiniment plus grave à partir du moment
où le pouvoir infléchir sa politique
est-ce que vous sentiez vous seriez
amené à sortir de la légalité
oui j'étais très inquiet je me rendais
compte que je vous serais mis devant
choix
dramatiquement un officier
dont
une des règles d'or la discipline et je
risquais de un jour de me dire est ce
que je dois
respecter cette discipline pas nous
sommes donc en 61 comment apprenez vous
qu'un putsch se prépare oui 20 ça s'est
passé
très près du bush
ça se passe le 21 avril et l'après midi
et a nommé officier puis à me voir je
savais qu'il était en liaison avec les
milieux dénommé activistes
et il me dit le général challe et al je
veux vous voir
donc pas ce moment-là vous saviez qu'il
y avait quelque chose qui se prépare est
puisque shalma pas dû être à alger oui
france et j'ai tout de suite compris
j'ai pas eu besoin qu'on me fasse un
dessin
j'ai dit vingt alosi comment la question
de votre participation au foot us au
postel pour vous monsieur plutôt ce
qu'on appelle un officier tradition j'ai
je préparais saint cyr
j'ai connu les thermaux qui ont
accompagné la guerre puisque j'ai été
arrêté par la gestapo
puis ensuite j'ai été envoyé en camp de
concentration de buchenwald où je
restais depuis deux ans
et puis après j'ai été libéré dans un
triste état en fait je me suis remis
assez vite et puis j'ai été militaire à
la légion étrangère tout le temps j'ai
fait trois séjours en indochine
voilà j'ai connu des choses qui m'ont
beaucoup marqué en particulier
l'abandon des populations indochinoise
sur le nez jésus les populations se
jeter à la mer déjà déjà
ensuite lorsque l'indochine est définie
on 54 nous avons rejoint l'algérie la
robine où commencer
mais revenons à votre rencontre avec le
général challe à la veille du budget
2010 va écouter ça marche je suis là il
faut achever cette victoire que nous
avions à 90%
entamée et je suis là
légalement pour faire
basculer toute l'armée pour que
l'algérie soit maintenu dans la france
préférait prévues pour cette nuit
je sais que c'est dur ce que je vous
demande mais qu'il dit mais je
je vais prétention est ce que vous
auriez pu faire couler le sang d'autres
français
est une idée qui m'a habité tout au long
de ces quatre jours à m
fondamentalement j'étais opposé mais
quelques france trouve
savez moi j'ai vu des musulmans dont le
sang a coulé et qu'ils étaient tous
l'aide française
donc après cette décision vous rentrez à
zéralda comment est ce que vous prenez
votre régiment ben
disons qu'un régiment de les gens n'a
pas besoin d'être pris en main quand un
officier désigné à sa tête et qu'on a
jugé voilà jugé digne d'en assumer la
responsabilité
c'est que les subordonnés l'acceptent et
lui obéisse donc je savais quel que soit
le côté dramatique de la situation que
le régiment
j'avais la prétention de croix qui
mesure le coût ne commence votre mission
est de prendre alger comment cela se
passe-t-il c'est à dire en ce qui
concerne le ré pleurait pas rempli
rapidement je crois efficacement en
unité très très manoeuvrière et très
aguerris qu'elle était il s'en cache la
mission qui lui avait été confié mission
délicate
le samedi 22 avril la population d'alger
apprenant l'opération insurrectionnelle
de salan challe jours les élèves
s'étaient massées sur le forum l'effet
de surprise avait été totale et du
balcon de la délégation générale les
auteurs du coup d'état pouvaient faire
acclamer leur triomphe éphémère
salon comme ses adjoints pensait alors
que leur complot avait abouti
mais trois jours plus tard à l'assemblée
monsieur debré disait de cette nouvelle
et terrible épreuve la france sortira
nul n'a d'autre
enfin le 25e s'est avéré que l'objectif
que s'était fixé le général challe à
savoir que l'armée bascule à ses côtés
de cris qui n'avait pas été atteint non
seulement elle n'avait pas été atteint
mais libre les unités qui au début
c'était rallier se sont rejoints leurs
contenants et ce sont des solidarités du
coup se fait alors l'effondrement
isolement des généraux la métropole
avait dit non et en quelques heures les
forces légales réoccuper la délégation
générale c'était fini
[Musique]
gimont été dissous alors l'après-midi
les parties les parties le départ de
zéralda était très émue et toute la
population européenne est musulmane
aussi qui s'est assemblées vont nous
dire on voit en triant algérie française
nous a offert des fleurs
et
moi avec mes officiers je suis resté
vous avez été arrêté oui j'ai été arrêté
lors j'étais récente et puis j'ai mon
procès vous avez été condamné à 10 ans
de réclusion criminelle vous en avez
effectué combien 5
lors j'étais à la santé puis à la prison
de clairvaux et puis ensuite à tulle
nous étions une dizaine simplement et
puis ensuite les et principaux inculpés
de le reste on est nous rejoindre ils se
sont retrouvés à la même prison le
général challe geiler ayral salon
général jours je suppose que vous avez
eu le temps de repenser au putsch
cependant vous étiez en prison oui
monsieur
c'est beaucoup de choses et s'il ya
d'autres il ya des choses qui vous sont
apparus je viens par là par exemple
est ce que vous n'avez pas sous-estimer
le devoir d'obéissance du soldat parce
que c'est quand même le premier devoir
d'obéissance comme de gaulle l'a rappelé
d'ailleurs été un peu mal placé pour le
rappeler ce qu'est la première chose
importante qui est fait dans son nom sa
carrière s'est désolé il faut pas
oublier que nos générations de soldats
ont été baignés dans l'élection du
général de gaulle qui un beau jour a
préféré
choisir l'honneur à l'obéissance
oui mais en même temps en algérie il ya
une situation qui a évolué entre 54 et
62 et votre fidélité à la parole donnée
nous empêche t elle pas de prendre en
compte cette évolution
peut-être que si on nous l'avait
expliqué cette solution s'il y avait eu
des cris du code du coeur et si on avait
discuté avec d'autres si on n'avait pas
discuté uniquement avec des gens dont on
savait pertinemment qu'ils allaient
assassiner les gens qui avaient pris les
armes à nos côtés
les accords d'evian ont été signés
uniquement avec nos adversaires pas avec
les gens qui s'était mouillé avec nous
mais est ce qu'au nom de cette fidélité
à une parole on n'aboutit pas une
situation toute évolution est impossible
c'est le drame
de l'état des soldats et d'officiers
grandeur et servitude midi
l'histoire vous a donné tort est-ce que
vous avez réfléchi à cet échec
oui bien sûr beaucoup
enfin
ce n'est pas parce qu'une cause
a échoué qu'elle cesse d'être juste
l'histoire est pleine causes justes qui
ont échoué
quand vous êtes revenu à la vie civile
et la libre vous sentez différence voilà
oui sûrement
je me sentais il ya une chose importante
c'est je me suis senti un petit peu
dépouillé de ma finalité puisque j'avais
perdu d'uniformes et pour moi le le
métier mika était qu une raison de vivre
et les métier que j'ai exercé après ont
été moyens de vie
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut tirer
des leçons de ce qui s'est passé en
algérie pour la période actuelle
d'abord je dois dire moi je n'oublie pas
tous et je crois que l'effort que l'on
fait pour
conserver le passé présent ça une grande
signification pour l'avenir
il ya des pères de ma vie la résistance
ce qui s'est passé en national gerri je
garde très présent dans ma mémoire et je
pense que ça une certaine signification
pour l'avenir on dit toujours que par
lourdes la france éternelle j'ai eu sa
langue livres d'histoire et j'apprends
ça mes enfants quand je leur apprends de
l'histoire mais
rien ne dit qu'une nation et éternelle
elle peut éclater et dans d'autres
conditions tout à fait différente ce qui
s'est passé pour l'algérie peut se
passer pour la corse peut se passer pour
la bretagne il ya des filles à des
leçons qu'il faut tirer la leçon
essentielle c'est qu'il ne faut pas
abandonner les gens qui veulent résister
français cette importance
[Musique]
dans cette algérie meurtrier bouleversé
l'armée française a pour mission
essentielle de rétablir l'ordre et
l'harmonie entre les deux communautés
française et musulmane
[Musique]
son ennemi numéro 1 c'est la peur la
peur que la rébellion fait peser sur ces
montagnes et sur ces douars par le
terrorisme le plus inhumain et le
plupart par
les assassins font la loi les rues sont
désertes
chacun s'enferme
menacée dans sa vie et dans c'est bien
le doigt rappeur lil obéit aux maîtres
de la m
francis jeanson vous avez aidé le fln
quelle était votre travail à ce moment
là
tout au début j'ai l'impression j'ai
surtout servi de chauffeur de taxi nous
responsables du fln qui se trouve être
en france et qu'il y avait des
difficultés à circuler dans paris parce
que la police les a arrêtés un peu trop
souvent sur le sur le faciès après ça
s'est compliqué il fallait trouver des
lieux de réunion il fallait trouver des
filières de passage des frontières pour
les algériens à qui quittait la france
ou qui devait entrer en france
et il a fallu aussi trouver des moyens
de rassembler les cotisations du fln et
qui était versée par les les militants
dans les différentes villes de france
grâce à anglet sur paris et ensuite les
expédié hors de france avant 1954 vous
étiez connu pour être un intellectuel
parisien à vis de sartre mais on peut se
demander comment vous en êtes vous venu
à vous intéresser aux événements
d'algérie parce que rien ne semblait
vous prédisposé à le faire les alliages
les ignorer pendant un certain temps
elle est fait et puis j'y suis venu en
48 49
et qu'est ce qui vous frappe le plus
dans les ca ce moment là oui d'andré
situation algérienne aux légumes frappés
le plus c'était que on s'efforce est de
bâillonner un peuple qui n'en étaient
plus à se laisser bâillonner c'est que
il y avait une énorme erreur commise en
mai 45 avec les massacres du
constantinois et que cette erreur était
en train de porter ses fruits sous la
forme d'une organisation profondeur du
peuple algérien même pour lutter contre
l'occupation française car c'était comme
ça dès lors que se posait le problème
donc tout ça allait dans le sens voilà
un peuple qui a voulu s'exprimer qui
s'est battu d'ailleurs aux côtés de la
france du désert et tant à la guerre et
dès qu'il a éprouvé le besoin de dire
vous savez nous existons
lui a dit vas te coucher et ça c'était
inexpiable et ça ne pouvait que conduire
à de grands de
à de grands soubresauts ça allait de soi
que
ces gens dans la mesure où ils me
disaient qu'ils avaient besoin de moi je
ne pouvais pas faire autrement que de
les aider puisque il me semblait que
leur causent d'été était juste vous
savez quand je parle d'une cause juste
je vis dans le relatif et je pense non
le relatif il n'y a pas de causes
absolues pour moi mais relativement
parlant leur cause était juste puisque
c'était la seule manière qu'ils avaient
exprimé c'était l'insurrection
il était entré à l'insurrection ils me
demandaient de les aider je ne voyais
pas pourquoi je ne les aurais pas aidé
étant donné que par ailleurs j'étais un
peu ennuyé quand même mais c'est un
euphémisme de dire ennuyé de penser que
c'était mon pays qui procédait comme ça
vis-à-vis d'eux
quels sont les sentiments que vous
gardez dans votre esprit de cette
période et s'angoissent kipré de ville
et non ce n'est pas peut-être pas
l'angoissé à laquelle vous songé je veux
dire que je n'ai jamais eu le sentiment
de risque et des choses à titre
personnel
j'avais une profonde inquiétude
qui était si nous commettons une erreur
ça va coûter très cher à nos camarades
je sais rien parce que eux au cas où il
était pris il risquait fort d'être
torturés et au delà
pour nous pensé que c'était peu probable
donc je m'inquiétais pas tellement pour
nous
[Musique]
par l'armée si la jeunesse française qui
reçoit la mission de résoudre le drame
algérien
[Musique]
et
par camions par train les unités vont
couvrir le pays d'un vaste filet
protecteur que l'on a baptisé
quadrillage
au moment vous aidiez le fln par votre
réseau par votre action il y avait des
soldats français qui était en train de
se battre en algérie et qui
éventuellement ont pu être tués par les
armes j'ai acheté avec l'argent vous
devez transporter qu'est ce que vous
pensez des accusations de trahison qui
ont été portées contre vous
oui oui je sais bien mais à ce moment là
il n'y a plus de signes a plus de raison
pour qu'une situation en viennent à se
terminer cordesse ici chaque fois en ce
sens lié par le passé on pourra plus
rien y changer alors ce qui me
paraissait évident c'est que les
trahisons elle avait eu lieu avant et
c'est que on se trouvait dans une
situation où la seule façon d'être
fidèle à ce qui a un sens à mes yeux
dans l'appartenance à un pays c'était de
c'était d'empêcher ce pays de continuer
à fonctionner de façon aussi lamentable
vis-à-vis de l'étranger ça je crois que
pour moi il n'y avait pas de problème
c'était là c'était une certaine france
qui trahissaient qui trahissait la
france bien avant qu'une nous soyons
entrés en jeu le problème que peut poser
votre action c'est surtout par rapport à
la violence le fln a fait les attentats
qui ont été atroces est-ce que ça n'a
pas fait hésiter quelques fois dans
votre engagement et je voulais dit tout
à l'heure je vis dans le relatif et je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait de cause
absolument injuste et et qu'ils puissent
se se défendre se soutenir
de façon idéale alors c'est un signe on
avait acculé un peuple fonctionner de
cette manière là ont ils eu l'affluence
était prévisible sous ce prétexte là moi
je ne voyais pas qu'on puisse aller
jusqu'à dire bon ben on renvoie les on
revoit les adversaires dos-à-dos non moi
je sais qui avait commencé et s'il est
si la violence telle que telle qu'elle
était pratiquée en algérie par le fln
avait atteint la france qu'est ce que
vous auriez fait ce mois mais ça a bien
failli se produire et quand j'ai senti
que c'était sur le point de se produire
chez signalé simplement que notre réseau
ne seraient pas d'accord pour soutenir
cette violence là mais c'était pas
c'était pas uniquement parce que c'était
des français qui auraient été en danger
à ce moment là il nous apparaissait que
d'une part c'était mettre en péril
tous les algériens de france il y en
avait quand même un sacré nombre
pour quelques aux quelques actions
évidemment très spectaculaire mais qui
serait sans lendemain et d'autre part
c'était
compromettre sans doute pour fort
longtemps toute possibilité de deux
rencontres
d'entente et de compréhension entre les
peuples algérien et français
nous la trahison la violence ça laissait
c'est une question d'appréciation à tout
moment il me semble qu'il faut qu'il y
ait dans une société donnée une part de
trahison j'appellerai mois une trahison
positive en fait qu'est ce que c'est que
trahir à certains égards c'est avoir un
pied d'un côté un pied de l'autre et
c'est construire un pont sur une rivière
c'est mettre en rapport de collectivités
de vie large de pays qui s'ignoraient
jusque là et qui aurait très bien pu se
taper sur laquelle porte est bien
on peut aussi essayer de procéder
différemment on peut essayer de faire
comprendre
les exigences de l'un à l'autre et des
six pompes dans
la trahison c'est ça aussi vous plaidez
pour une éventuelle possibilité d'un
fidélité au passé mais on évolue pas
dans la fidélité rigoureuse au passé
c'est à dire quand on est complètement
aliénés parce qu'il ya déjà eu lieu
est-ce que c'était cet épisode de votre
vie vous engager sur une voie qui n'aura
pas de celle là si vous l'aviez pas vécu
non je ne crois pas je ne crois pas je
considère que ça a été un épisode
évidemment très très fort très très
passionnant je dirais mais
j'étais je vous le disais je crois tout
à l'heure j'ai été très soulagé quand ça
a été fini et et pour le reste les
activités que j'ai pu mener depuis lors
ne sont quand même apparu d'une certaine
manière plus concrète dans la mesure où
elle n'était pas en rapport avec des
événements exceptionnels né avec la vie
quotidienne de mes compatriotes et et ça
en même temps si vous voulez je ne crois
pas avoir fait à ce moment-là autre
chose que ce que j'essaie de faire
maintenant c'est à dire
essayer d'amener les les gens à
réfléchir et à réfléchir en commun sur
les situations qui sont nécessairement
fort complexe essayez aussi de les aider
à poser les problèmes dans le relatif
depuis dimanche alger à ces barricades
trois jours sont passés barricades
devant la grand'poste barricades aux
facultés tout un quartier d'alger est
fermé comme le café d'ortiz qui porte un
nom prestigieux le forum
le pc d'ortiz c'est maintenant plutôt ce
premier étage face au plateau des
glières d'où ses lieutenants d'heure en
heure harangue la foule des algérois
[Musique]
certains agissent longtemps après en
insurrection
ils ont tiré sur le service d'ordre ils
ont tué de bon soldat
il se dresse en armes contre l'autorité
de la france à partir des événements qui
s'est passé en 56 ou les pieds noirs les
manifestations pieds noirs ont fait
céder guy mollet et à partir des
événements surtout de 58 ou les pieds
noirs ont quand même
abattu de république pour mettre au
pouvoir de gaulle et la vème république
on a eu l'impression très nette que nous
nous étions relativement puissant et
capable d'infléchir le cours des
événements bon à partir de ce moment là
les événements tels qu'ils se déroulent
l attitude du gouvernement français
déplaisant nous déplaisant
on a fait une nouvelle manifestation
de façon à infléchir à nouveau le cours
de l'histoire quand vous dites nous
avons fait une belle manifestation
voulez dire que vous avez participé aux
barricades ne faut pas se faire
d'illusions quand on quand je dis nous
c'est nous c'est tous les pieds noirs il
y avait
une quasi unanimité
de la population française algérie a
dans ces manifestations
mais les barricades se termine comme on
le sait sous la pluie avec des gens qui
s'en vont penaud et est battu oui pour
moi c'était de signes le premier c'est
celui que nous n'avions plus réellement
de pouvoir réfléchir le cours des
événements et le second c'est une
impression d'abandon
de séparation très nette entre la france
et les français d'alger me semble que là
il ya après les barricades un point de
rupture qui se passe et le drame du
putsch peut-être ça a été de relancer un
nouveau l'espoir
chez ces gens là qui d'une certaine
manière pouvait c'est beaucoup de ces
gens en tout cas qui nous certaine
manière pouvait avoir pris leur parti de
de l'inévitable et
moi je suis en contact avec des gens
doit s par
quelqu'un qui est venu me voir et
qui m'a 10 ont plus ou moins fait
rentrer dans le coup
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas l'impression du
tout à ce moment là et maintenant non
plus que l'eau est à ce moment là était
vraiment une tendance ultra beau mais
c'est quand même une tendance qui
cherchent à garder l'algérie française
voilà alors s'ils gardent l algérie
française c'est être ultra ce moment là
où ils sont ultra
c'est un nouvel espoir
qui apparaît et
on n'a jamais pu exister un espoir et ce
nouvel espoir
la quasi-totalité
de le pied-noir plonge à nouveau dans
cet espoir est bon le putsch arif c'est
l'échec que l'on sait et à ce moment là
je crois à part est une autre wes celle
dont on a surtout gardé le souvenir
et effectivement elle deviendrait
violence sans doute parce que ce dernier
espoir s'est teinté fendrait les gens
doivent trouver dans le dans cette forme
d'action très dur assez désordonné
quelquefois une façon de de ne pas
penser à ce que sera demain
mais à partir du moment où on avait la
quasi-certitude
d'être une erreure du reste mais la
quasi certitude que
on voulait mettre la porte à ce moment
là on peut expliquer toutes sortes de
réactions même très violente ce matin-là
alger a été brusquement arrachés au
sommeil par une série de violentes
déflagrations
plus de 120 explosions se sont succédé
aux quatre coins de la ville et les
dégâts matériels ont été considérables
[Musique]
c'était c'était une sorte d'idéologie
qui consistait à partir d'un certain
moment à faire créer un barrage total
une séparation complète entre les
français et les savanes
bon bien sûr ça ça n'avait n'avait pas
grand sens et on savait pas trop à quoi
à quoi ça pouvait aboutir mais ça a été
une réaction qui a été voulue évidemment
par certains sous peu nous raconter
quelques quelques secousses et des
stages tous ancrés dans la mémoire à
propos de oui bon l'exemple le plus qui
à mon sens est le plus significatif
c'est sans doute celui des
décades femme de ménage qui sur le sur
le télé m'y attendais
l'autobus pour rentrer chez elle une
voiture est passée et
bon elles ont été abattues
avec quelques rafales de mitraillettes
moi j'ai assisté personnellement à à bab
el oued à une ratonnade ce qu'on appelle
une ratonnade
et c'est directement cette ratonnade il
y avait une gamine
du quartier qui avait été
violer et tuer en forêt daïna
et locked 2 de son enterrement
il ya des gens qui ont voulu la venger
est bon pour les venger pour la venger
il s'agissait simplement de tuer le plus
possible
d'arabe quelle était votre sentiment
quand tu avais une chose comme ça qui se
passait mais personnellement je dois
dire que
je j'étais dans mon quartier à cette
époque là et que j'ai trouvé ça a
commencé à crépiter un peu partout et
j'ai trouvé dans une petite impasse au
coin d'une maison il y avait 4
4 petits arraché et fait monter dans
la deux chevaux de ma femme
s'était couché sur la chaussée par terre
et dix ans que je les ai sortis de là
de la ratonnade je les ai lâché je me
suis toujours étonné d'ailleurs du sort
pourquoi il m'avait fait confiance parce
que finalement il fait aucune espèce de
raison de monter avec moi
est ce que vous auriez pu commettre des
violences contre des carafes moi je n'ai
jamais commises mais je ne suis pas sûr
que moi avec très peu de différences et
des textes dans les étangs l'expérience
je ne suis pas sûr que j'aurais pas pu
aussi commettre des actes de violence
la majorité des gens
n'a prouvé certainement pas
les actes de l'aurès
je ne pense pas au moins d'entendre ces
actes extrêmes
parce que cette violence quotidienne en
face c'est au point où vous ne pouviez
pas savoir en partant de chez vous le
matin pour les férus marché si vous
n'avez pas trébucher ou marché dans le
sens donc de cadavres
les gens ne pouvaient pas accepter c'est
pas possible qu'il a accepté mais
il restait solidaire de leur s parce que
l'ol c'était à ce moment là le seul
recours
contre contre la le départ avec la mise
à la porte l'algérie
à marseille plusieurs paquebots déjà
sont arrivés avec à leur bord 300 800 on
se sent passagers qui ont quitté
l'algérie
voyages de vacances pour certains mais
pour d'autres ce voyage met-il pas sans
retour
[Musique]
l'avenir enfin ce qui m'apparaissait en
france
c'était ce n'est pas exact ans
c'était long zitrone
guy lux et le tiers 16 par rapport à ce
que j'avais vécu ça me paraissait
vraiment dérisoire
est ce que par rapport à ce passé mon
historique que se passait d'histoire
vous avez vécu en algérie vous savez
garder les mêmes sentiments commencent
que vous le considérez maintenant
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé en algérie
depuis
depuis la conquête c'est mon histoire
ça fait partie de mon patrimoine
et à ce titre je suis complètement
solidaire de tous les événements qui se
sont produits de tous les gens qui ont
participé à ces événements
je veux dire que je me sens jusqu'en 62
complètement solidaire aussi bien du fln
que de l'ouest
je ne sais pas du tout de faire
des prévisions oecuméniques sais mais
c'est une vision historique des choses
que j'essaie d'avoir
et je je je me trouve assez bien
finalement c'est assez difficile à
comprendre puisque vous étiez d'un côté
quand même il a fallu qu'il y ait le fln
pour qu'il y ait l'oas pour qu'il y ait
la guerre et c'est ça ce titre là que je
l'assumé comme étant l'histoire de mon
pays parce que l'algérie qu'on le
veuille ou pas c'est mon pays
mais est ce que ce pays dont vous parlez
est ce qu'il existe encore non alors il
se trouve que moi ce vécu après en
algérie jusqu'en 68 et bien sûr le pays
existe le décor existe
les maisons sont toujours là mais c'est
un sentiment d'
traiterait déchirant
de passer dans une rue où vous êtes
passé pendant des années des années
alors que vous saviez à quel étage de
telles maisons de talent immob il y
avait un talent qui habitait que tel
magasin était tenu par le père de intel
avec lequel vous étiez
au lycée et de retrouver le même cadre
sans la même vie avec une vie tout à
fait différente
c'est comme si on avait vidé quelque
chose de toute sa substance
et à ce titre là évidemment l'algérie
que nous avons connue
n'existe plus et n'existera plus jamais
faut bien que les gens qui ont quelques
nostalgie
sache que de cette algérie n'existe pas
une histoire à plusieurs
il voit durant un prêt service militaire
de 34 mois vous décidez cependant de
vous engager dans service des affaires
algériennes
tessin alors ce service des affaires
algériennes fonctionner sur la base de
gens qui étaient soit officier de
carrière soit officiers de réserve qui
était bon quart réserviste
donc là je prends un engagement de trois
ans là précisément et je peux vous dire
une chose curieuse c'est que dès ce
moment-là 59 quand je prends
l'engagement de trois ans je sais
qu'avec ces trois ans une situation se
terminera
si certains attise la haine par la
violence au nom d'un fanatisme déchets
d'autres ont choisi le calmer les
esprits non en répondant à la violence
par la violence mais en faisant un
effort de compréhension de tolérance ses
lèvres de pacification qui s'accomplit
au sein des sas c'est à dire des
sections administratives spécialisées
dont l'âme est l'officier ok bible ce
village est en difficulté le maire a été
assassiné un képi bleus va commencer là
une émouvante mission son programme un
sourire sa signature une poignée de main
son cheval de bataille angie
je suis affecté
comme chef d'une sas dans la région de
palestro
cette sas avait été déchirée par un
drame aussi abominable en ce sens que
l'homme qui en assumait la
responsabilité précédemment qui étaient
des officiers français se croyant trahi
par son marcel
bond ans on avait exécuté un certain
nombre avait exécuté un certain nombre
de ces hommes qui étaient des gens
originaires du village qui était la
soirée côté
nous dire que la suite de cet événement
tragique
le rapport entre la sas et la population
locale était quelque chose de le temps
du et c'est un mot faible
jugé que je prends c'est une attitude
d'ouverture totale envers la population
de de confiance même vu de l'extérieur
une confiance qui pouvait paraître un
peu comment dirais-je un peu folle un
peu naïve même en fait les choses le
prétendre elle n'était ni folie unis
naïveté de ma part elle était le jeu de
vivre qui veut les jouer et je savais
qu'elle correspondait à une attente de
la population
je vois des goûters dont il ya quelques
postes à prendre s à ce jeu peut
recruter du personnel
j'en ai recrutés on a discuté de ça on a
parlé des évènements tragiques précédent
jeu derrière camoufler je prends cherché
à justifier ni la france ni le
malheureux homme qui avait que nous ce
crime
on a reconstitué un climat qui
permettait de faire ce pour quoi nous
étions là c'est à dire une meilleure
administration
ntia pas un paradoxe de la situation
parce qu'au fond vous savez très bien
que la dépendance va arriver mais en
même temps par ces actions positives
vous entraîner la population du côté de
l'armée française donc vous la mettez en
situation fosse pour pour l'avenir
oui c'est vrai votre question est
judicieuse les tubas c'est peut-être
aberration matin mais j'avoue que
vous avez surtout les le sentiment pour
moi mais c'est peut-être fulgence que je
dis mon passé le sentiment que j'avais à
l'époque
de les entraîner du côté de leur propre
épanouissement leur propre risque d'une
prise de conscience
alors bon peut-être
[Musique]
peut-être
je me voile est le regard n'est ce pas
sur un certain nombre de réalités qui
télé réalité de l'histoire du moment là
je me tourne vers les dirigeants de
l'insurrection
je leur dis car que nous les attendons
ici
pour trouver avec eux
une fin honorable au combat qui se
traînent encore
le progressivement on sent bien qu'il ya
quelque chose d'inéluctable dans cette
histoire est que
quelles que soient les résistances
quelles que soient les drames aussi des
déchirements ce que l'on appelle
l'indépendance de l'algérie à intervenir
là surgit en histoire maman
ce qui m'inquiétait terriblement c'était
le sort de ceux qui s'étaient ou qui
avait été engagé du côté disons des
forces françaises parce que je craignais
je crois bien qu'on ait sa bombe de 100
kg
des bus 62
compte tenu d'un certain nombre
d'instructions données par les autorités
françaises espèrent dans les faits se
confirme le fait que à ces braves gens
un petit mot race ni ses terrains on va
leur dire bien revoir merci rentrez chez
vous vous serez bien tranquille attendez
la suite des événements on cherche à les
rassurer
roche cherche à les apaiser en leur
disant mais vous ne risquez rien on se
trompe qui je viens de vous arrivera
excepté en fait en fait tout est à
craindre quant à leur sort n'est ce pas
parce que on sait bien et on l'a vu même
en france à certaines périodes de
l'histoire pas si lointaine ne serait-ce
que les règlements de comptes après les
événements de cette nature et coûte cher
à ceux qui sont censés être les perdants
est cependant la vampire
ces hommes ces musulmans sont des
morasses mais il faisait partie de
l'armée française étaient chargés
d'assurer la sécurité des sas
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire
ouais
suivre et l'armée jusqu'à ce qu'ils me
disent la quitter et alors qu'est ce que
vous ferez je sais pas il faut que je
fais entre les mains
et nouveau concurrent
décidée
est ce que vous croyez que
votre vie sera en danger à ce moment-là
homogène
oui
jusqu'ici a vu les drapeaux
travailler sous les drapeaux français
vous croyez qu'il y aura obligatoirement
des comptes à régler après
supra leur chef me
surprenait recherche oui enfin le
dernier française va rester ici encore
pendant trois ans quand même
j'entendais parler nous
on notera pendant trois ans oui
il y aura rien de changé alors
certains complètement désespéré d'être
abandonné sur le terrain en haute
kabylie en particulier se sont couchés
dans les villes et gmc qui en mai ce qui
était leur compagnon d'armes mais qui
eux étaient français à part entière
alors ce qui me à ce moment là aussi
va être terriblement dur pour moi et a
laissé des traces assez longtemps
c'est que je constate que beaucoup de
français de responsables qu'ils soient
militaires ou civils
un comportement d'une assez grande
lâcheté une assez grande hypocrisie
après avoir dit vous savez vous les
supplétifs on ne vous abandonnera pas on
les voit disparaître après les autres
entrées en france bien sûr je comprends
leur souci de s'en sortir leurs soucis
petit arrière
l'envahît toujours dur
enfin moi ça m'a beaucoup marqué d'avoir
des gens préféraient leur salle à manger
un allah un peu de loyauté envers des
hommes et beaucoup ont préféré la salle
à manger chez toi c'est voyez ce que je
veux j'avais encore un petit bout de
contrats accompli on en fait je
démissionne c'est accepter et quoi
pourquoi vous quittez ce commandement
soit libre de mes mouvements possibles
mais mouvement dans l'action que je mène
car si j'obéis si je reste dans comment
dirais-je semblables dans l'appareil il
n'est ce pas bon il ya une hiérarchie
toujours pays sa très longue
d'instruction
et on organise une sorte de gangs où
viennent se réfugier des supplétifs qui
veulent partir ils apprennent que à
palestro il ya une petite chance d'être
protégé et d'avoir un espoir de partir
si bien que l'effectif pompiers de ces
espèces de campements grossi assez
considérablement il devait bien y avoir
environ 3000 personnes
l'enquêté la recherche à vous écarter de
l'endroit où vous êtes ah oui bien sûr
on va bien voir disparaître d'ailleurs
tous les moyens enfin je n'arrive
d'essuyer quelques petits coups de feu
un qu'on peut appeler on va appeler des
attentats n'ont pas bon pas bien c'est
ça c'est cesser ces risques il faut
prendre quand on mène une action
bon finalement en juin ses supplétifs
rentrer en france alors des décisions
plus l'art sont prises dans d'autres
régions d'algérie
[Applaudissements]
en france alors là va commencer autre
chose c'est
celle installations c'est l'assertion
dans la population française et croyez
moi ce ne fut pas du gâteau non plus
c'est un autre type si vous voulez de
d'action mais ce ne fut pas lieu
on sent très nettement que bombes la
mâchoire la sphère d'algérie et terminer
ces gens là
ne que vient-il faire n'est-ce pas
pourquoi vient-il nous déranger
et bien c'est une grande influence sur
ma vie en ce sens que depuis ce moment
là je crois que les seuls qui
m'intéressent sont les plus paumés
les damnés de la terre que l'on dit et
je fais pas du romantisme en ce moment
parce que vous savez les gens bien j'en
suis prévenu les gens bien
j'ai trop vu
tous les alibis tous le savent manipuler
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'aisance parce
que généralement ils sont les acquis
culturels ils ont les acquis de pouvoir
aussi qui leur permettent de se tirer
blanchi de toute situation même pas
vraiment les fassions même la plus
dégueulasse tandis que les peaux mais
quand ils sont
grandioses quand histoire les écrase
ils ont bien bien bien du mal
à trouver qui va laisser tiennent pas
être écrasé et moi je suis vous voulez
je terminerais pour répondre à votre
question en disant ceci j'ai au moins
appris une chose c'est que suit le côté
des paumés
on a commencé à porter notre regard sur
cette histoire là il nous paraissait
d'abord des évidences pour nous il était
clair que notre pays dont le peuple
algérien notre peuple a est évident pour
lui que le combat qu'il a mené pour se
libérer du système colonialiste c'était
un combat légitime et on ne peut plus
légitime ce n'est pas la question pour
nous de gagner quoi que ce soit de ce
combat qui a donné beaucoup de
souffrance mais qui a rendu aussi dans
liberté un peuple et qui lui a donné la
possibilité de reprendre en main son
destin quand vous dites que vous
reconnaissez qu'il fallait
l'indépendance jerry bon vous condamnez
vos parents en disant une chose pareille
quand j'ai dit que le combat était
légitime pour le peuple algérien afin
d'acquérir sa liberté nous avons aussi
appris que les choses n'étaient pas
aussi évidente la france était le
système convient il s'était installé
dans le maghreb depuis depuis 130 ans et
plus nos parents bombe c'était des gens
qui est qui qui n'avait pas du tout la
consoeur ils sont nés avec ce coin et
nice mais qu'ils aient dominé vous êtes
jeune français moi et ma femme
est ce que ça veut dire que vous ne vous
sentez plus algérien 3d troubler elle
sent bien que ce français pour
et vous ne pensez que vous ne
regretterez jamais jamais jamais jamais
c'est votre pays natal pourtant
je
n'avais moi j'ai envie je qui s'est
plongé les roms maintenant je pense que
les rangs génie
tu te plais ici
tu préfère être ici ou est en algérie
oui j'étais à quel endroit d'algérie
pourquoi tu préférais l'algérie
mon père jean
tout ça c'est les années de doutes et
ténèbres mais mes besoins et de sortie
est ce que vous pouvez dire comment vous
l'avez fait on sait très bien qu'on
avait besoin de tout ce qui est culturel
allemand français et de tout ce qui est
culturellement d'algérie et on sentait
que petit à petit on avait plus besoin
de rabâcher enfin de d'être
obligatoirement d'accord avec nos
parents pour résoudre nos problèmes en
fait d'être avec eux autour d'accords
avec une culture ou avec une autre c'est
à dire qu'on pouvait assumer les deux
cultures et on pouvait s'exprimer même
en assumant les deux cultures et vivre
eux et avoir deux c'est ça qui a motivé
la création de notre mouvement ne me qui
très important pour nous et pour notre
ville bon il fallait bien un point de
départ le point de départ c'était
d'abord de nous retrouver dans à travers
de ce qui est spécifique la mosquée la
construction des mosquées est allée elle
est bien implantée mis à s'inquiéter
c'est un cheminement qui est qui qui
nous est propre en tant que maghrébins
mais c'était aussi l'expression d'une
rencontre avec une autre communauté qui
acceptaient ont transformé une église
dans un lieu de prière musulman
[Musique]
c'est symboliquement comme remise quoi
la communauté chrétienne qui remet un
ancien édifice à la communauté musulmane
je crois que c'est un geste
ça a été spontanée tous les maghrébins
sont venus et ceux qui ont pris en
charge les travaux de la mosquée
là je pu re découvrir quelque sorte mon
père pouvoir rire pourra parler avec lui
pouvoir le sentir vivant dans ma famille
ça a été quelque chose de très important
nous avoir commencé à avoir une vie
familiale normale
puisque nous avons recommencé à
considérer des fêtes nous avons pour la
première fois nous avons pu fêter
quelque chose en famille les fêtes
religieuses
concernées sont l'un des lieux en dehors
de nous retrouver moi-même et de
retrouver le sens à ma vie je retrouvais
aussi le sens de ce qui pourrait mettre
en rapport avec un homme qui mon père
c'est le plus important
de femmes et hommes
[Musique]
on a appris qu'il faut toujours aller en
avoir il faut toujours être toujours
maîtres ne plus faire le premier pas
nous sommes une génération qui
condamnait à faire le premier pas
pour avancer pour aller à la découverte
de l'autre finalement c'est à dire de la
vie ce que je veux vous redire ce que
nous avons les moyens maintenant
d'assumer notre notre destin
[Musique]